I just stand by our hearts this beat
yeah that's fine there
you don't like fishing
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody was going on belay here I'm
currently backstage at the show and
you're waiting for comedian John doar to
finish rehearsing his stand-up set so we
could talk to the first comedian on our
show somebody has to say welcome Sir
Walter absolutely absolutely so uh
frisk me on Conan and your set is
actually a little bit complicated
complicated there's water falling from
the ceiling at some point there's a baby
pool involved I've learned it's easier
than writing jokes that's some kind of
employing people it's more like a
production yeah but the carrot-top myth
it hasn't been easy exactly my hero
yeah you're a genius yeah yeah often
Lenny Bruce my heroes I love it have you
seen Lenny Bruce's prop stuff so we're
on cable
we're on TBS and even though we're on
cable there's still some complications
some things you can't say and you had a
little trouble with your set explain
what what happens yeah not necessarily
trouble but interesting because I am a
great a great comedian and writer which
I'm not part of the joke that people
have seen it I've drawn a penis on my
chest of course this is how I had first
done the penis when you normally do this
joke this is the penis this is the go to
penis yeah can you get a shot of this
right here just the go-to penis my
corporate closer is this thank you
Microsoft goodnight standards and
practices came back you don't want FF
everybody know of course in the first
penis that the straw was this a side
view shaft one testicle kinda looks like
a paperclip bent out of shape as does my
penis
girls used to call me that bent out of
shape paperclip old paper clips coming
by tonight yeah it's gonna be a party
hope you don't have braces Oh God
what JP fought for an extra testicle
well we hold ourselves to a higher
standard of which done before now this
is what I get ready draw on my body two
testicles no pronounced head and no
ejaculate now would you rather here's
the question for you would you rather
have an extra
and you can see John's performance as
well as a whole bunch of other awesome
clips on Team Coco comm jondura thank
you very much
Aaron thank and I heard you John Dory
it's John Orr I'm fine very weird no
it's great
well you're a pin all right let's just
do that last thing there quick so I
don't say John Dory like a cool I love
John Dory really I'm fine with it